the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
I have two functions here one is ad and
one is multiply the add function returns
the sum of X plus y and the multiply
function just prints the value of x
times y what doesn't return the value
instead it's going to implicitly return
none right because we don't have any
return statement inside mult
so there are four lines here and the
question was how many total lines of
output will show up if you run the code
okay so how many lines in the console
show up so when I do first add one two
it's going to go inside this function
here and it's a it says X is 1 Y is 2
and return 3 so I'm replacing this line
with 3 but notice I'm never printing it
out so this line of code will not print
out anything instead if I do so I did so
the next line is if I print add 2 plus 3
then I'm going to get 5 and I'm going to
print that out so that's one one thing
I'm printing out next line says multiply
3 & 4 so I'm going to go inside my multi
function and say X is 3 y is 4 so I'm
going to print 12 3 times 4 is 12 so
that's another thing that gets printed
out and I'm not doing anything with the
output or the sorry I'm not doing
anything with a return from mult
so that line is is done and the last one
is is the trickiest and it says print
mult
5 so first I'm going to go in here X is
4 y is 5 and I'm printing 20 so that's
another print and the return of this
function is going to be none right and
the main thing here is I'm going to
print the return of this function so I'm
also going to print out none so that's
another one so in total I'm going to
have four different things printed out
the last one being this none
you